and i just don't know how i'm ever gonna
get over this i don't know how i'm gonna
move past this
90-day fiance star jeffrey paschall
sentenced to 18 years in prison without
the possibility of parole after being
convicted of kidnapping and assaulting
his ex-fiance the next thing i remember
he was beating me the sentencing comes
after a jury found the 44 year old
guilty of aggravated kidnapping domestic
assault and interference with emergency
calls in october
according to the knox county tennessee
district attorney's office jeffrey
physically assaulted his then fiance in
june of 2019. the d.a says jeffrey quote
grabbed the victim by the neck and
slammed her head against the wall
several times she was also thrown to the
ground and dragged
at the time the da's office also
reported that jeffrey quote took the
victim's cell phone and did not allow
her to leave the residence
the ordeal ended when jeffrey's ex fled
to a neighbor's house after he fell
asleep when officers arrived on the
scene they noted a large bruise on the
victim's forehead along with bruises and
abrasions on her back arms and the
inside of her lip
she was diagnosed with a concussion
at trial the reality star testified that
the victim's bruises were self-inflicted
but the jury disputed his testimony and
found him guilty as charged
going into this trial jeffrey had prior
convictions including possession with
intent to sell a controlled substance
and two federal drug trafficking charges
those were factored into his 18-year
sentencing i'm leaving
i'm going home jeffrey starred in season
4 of 90 day fiance before the 90 days
when cameras documented his trip to
russia to meet his online girlfriend
varya after the allegations against him
came to light some viewers called for
his removal and tlc decided not to
invite him on that season's tell-all
special